during the pandemic i ask everyone the
first few questions
i'm going to ask you guys uh what tv
series would you love to guest
write and direct i'll go first because i
really watch
fargo i loved
i love how it changes every season it
reinvents
itself it's brilliantly directed it's
constantly fresh
and original it's like very cinematic
it's like telling
a movie every year well we've been guest
directing on succession
um but i would love to guest right on it
i would love to take a crack at it
because i just love the
i just love the characters so much and
uh i feel like i'm starting to get the
rhythm of how they speak
you know and uh it's just a wealth of
riches that show
100 um what movie what movie or movies
do you guys think you've seen the most
i'm gonna say willy wonka
i think i started watching that movie
very young
and if it's on i keep it on and i think
it's been a continuum
since my youth so i i kind of feel like
i know every word of that
uh movie um
the dude what's uh uh
rick lebowski we i know we saw it like
three times in the movie theater
so and then subsequently
you know 150 times
you know streaming on tv and it never
it never gets boring i can watch it
again
right now i 100 agree uh last
fun question if you will um if you could
get the financing to make
anything tomorrow what would you make
and why we've often talked about making
uh
the razor's edge again i feel like it's
never done
it's never been done well um
and it's it's just such an amazing book
and
you know those those kind of period epic
films are hard to
hard to get financing for what else
the story of jane jacobs and how she
saved
how she fought uh robert moses
and saved uh basically new york city
washington square park but basically
saved
new york from what happened to the bronx
she's like the shiro that has not gotten
her props
that sounds awesome uh jumping into your
movie
i am curious how long it took you to
talk indiana jones
uh with karen when she was on set
immediately how long did we continue the
conversation
i mean she had so many great stories
about that and you know she was so
instrumental in the shaping of that
character
um you know she deserves a lot of credit
for
what i think is probably you know
one of the greatest female characters on
screen
um and you know she's got great stories
and we i don't think we've heard them
all but i'd like to
yeah i would it would have been me all
day uh so you remember that time you did
that movie with spielberg
and she was very generous at sharing
them too
and she's a great storyteller so you
would have been very happy
i would have loved it what was it about
the book that said
we want to make this and turn this into
a movie well
we've always wanted to make a movie in
the hudson valley we uh
it's our part-time home and we love the
spookiness and the beauty and the drama
of the setting and we've always been
fans of the hudson river school of art
and here was this book that had all of
that in it
and we've always wanted to make you know
a
kind of uh this kind of horror movie
we've talked about it a lot
and you know it just landed in our laps
i contacted the writer and i said
you know shari read it she loved it and
we were just we kind of hit it off
and it happened i'm always curious about
the editing process because that's the
final rewrite
could you sort of talk about what you
learned in the editing room
and how it helped shape the final um the
final locked picture
well you know this movie was the first
movie that us and like everybody else in
the world
edited remotely because we rapped right
before the pandemic so
it was like a whole other experience
sort of not sitting
in the room with the editor um but
talking the way we're talking right now
um but that being said i mean i think
this was a movie
we had too much movie so so much of our
process
was finding the bone like the real
structure of the movie through the
editing process
and deciding how much we wanted the
audience to know about each character at
what point in the story
because the story has a kind of unusual
uh
take on you know i i feel like people
emerge in the story that becomes
sympathetic maybe you didn't expect and
vice versa so
you know how much do we reveal that each
person that was something we talked
about
a lot in the editing well that's that's
actually what i wanted to address
is that there's layers of the onion that
you're pulling back as you're watching
and this is the kind of movie i would
imagine that normally you'd want to put
it in front of like
a test screening audience and know like
and find out what
what where where are the where's the
audience figuring this out
um so how did you sort of do that during
covet
that was incredibly you're you're
hitting on a real problem
and normally before you even do a test
screening audience
as filmmakers you just bring people in
people you trust
people you know come to the editing room
we'll have some drinks you'll watch the
movie you'll give us your feedback you
know
none of that like none of it i've never
made a movie like
where literally no one saw it you know
it was
it was crazy but we did at some point
start sending cuts to
to our trusted people um
you know people that we've known for
years other film many are
are filmmakers many are editors many are
you know and and and even though there
wasn't this
in-person thing you couldn't hear how
they react i mean that's you read the
room
like we miss that ability to be when
people are shuffling around
you know they're bored they don't have
to tell you you hear it you know or if
everybody gets up to go to the bathroom
at the same time you're like oh maybe we
are
our pacing's off if everybody's gasping
you know you've got them you know so
we had none of that we had no there was
we've never
had that experience it had to be done
all through
sending a link and then getting feedback
i can't imagine that um i already have
to wrap i'm gonna say good luck with all
your speed dating today
and congrats on the movie thank you
thank you